John asks when you're in a funk what do
you do to get out of it John you've
asked a question that I've been really
excited to share with the world because
it works it is very dark like this is
dark so like I know that most people
when they share my content say beware
potty mouth McGee
this one's beware you'd be like
frightened with a little bit of like a
tear drop on your left eye left I'm
gonna tell you the truth because that
was the commitment when I decided to do
this which you know obviously I'm able
to well Steve's carrying the questions
but I could always kibosh them so it's
it's when I start doing these live or
when we do live events or we take this
show in the road and it's audience
participation then it'll really be the
full monty but for now I'm I'm answering
them and I'm answering them truthfully
this is a dark one I'm stalling cuz it's
dark it's it's dark when I'm in a funk I
literally close my eyes put myself into
a place where something remarkable
happens to me uh you know you know CNN
names me the greatest man of all time
you know like like just literally like
silly things like I get on a list of
being the best entrepreneurs or or
Birchbox sells for four billion dollars
and I make a lot of money or the full
extreme when I'm in my most funk I
literally try usually I do things that
are realistic and happen within a
one-year window but in my deepest funks
I'll a project this is harder still
little more roleplay because when I
think about stuff that's gonna happen
intimately it feels real but I'll dream
about buying the Jets and I'll think
about those great things and then I
literally I literally make pretend that
Birchbox sells and I make millions and
millions of dollars and that that's the
phone call and the next phone call is
from my hysterical sister telling me
that my mother died in a car accident
and I really do that and I really go
there and I very like like I'm very as
you guys know me I'm an emotional
character I go there and it really does
something interesting for me I really
don't care that I made seven million
dollars if my mom died I just really
don't and I can even as I'm telling you
this right now
I can feel it I can truly feel how
little I care about that in in
comparison to what I would feel with
that pain and very honestly it just sets
me straight it just reminds me what my
priorities are and it allows me to
understand that the health of my
children or my wife I mean the fear and
the the shivers I get when I think about
their passing in you know in real life
like them dying and it just sets me so
straight it just makes me realize how
non important losing that client was or
that best employee or that deal or that
opportunity passing on uber in the first
round which would have given me one
hundred million dollars in paper so they
got to go public but it's pretty damn in
there it's something I can deal with
because the truth is it's just not what
makes me happy and more importantly I'm
so happy that everybody I love has been
healthy for so long losing grandparents
early has put me in that position so a
negative is a positive and and that's
what I do
I go in a very strange cocoon and make
pretend the people I love the most died